Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier vor dem Salon, möchten euch ein Jahresende-Angebot einen klugen Gedanken geben. Mit dem Buch sind wir heute sehr gut bedient, glaube ich. Spektakulär. Oder?
Es hilft, wenn man Statistiken lesen kann.
Ja, bilanzieren ist nicht verkehrt. Und auch der ein oder andere Gedanke, der sich bei mir so verfestigt hat, aus See- und Sprechgewohnheit, ist vielleicht noch mal zu überprüfen.
Oh, ja, also man wird wirklich geschult in einem Denken, dass man viel zu wenig sonst leistet oder auch geleistet bekommt. Das ist einfach unglaublich, wenn wir einen Ökonomen haben, also Branko Milanovic, der eigentlich Experte für globale Einkommensungleichheit ist, aber von dort ausgehend dann sich fragt, wie verändert sich die Welt geopolitisch? Er hat die richtigen Zahlen dann zur Hand und hat jetzt nicht solche, wie in Deutschland beliebten Spiele, ja, was will der Putin da und was möchte Trump dort machen? Er schaut einfach auf die ganz großen Zahlen und die großen Veränderungen der letzten Jahrzehnte. Es ist so unglaublich, was dann plötzlich zutage tritt und dieses ganze psychologische Wühlen in ist der Xi vielleicht eher so oder so, spielt gar keine Rolle mehr.
Ja, am Ende assortiert sie nicht ganz aus, aber tut sie einfach alle in einen Topf. Xi, Putin, Trump und es ergibt dann auch Sinn, wenn man das liest.
Ja.
Also seid gespannt auf den.
Und sagt aber auch, die anderen sind im Prinzip auch so angedockt an diese ganze Entwicklung. Ja, also er fragt auch wirklich bei all der Fokussierung auf die großen Leute, die Geschichte machen, inwieweit sind die eigentlich determiniert. Und diese Determination, die führt er mit Zahlen vor, wie ich das so noch nicht gesehen habe.
Genau. Er lädt auch wirklich ein zu Gedankenexperimenten. Wir haben jetzt Merkel immer unter dem 16 Jahre Stillstand, Fähnchen in den Wind hängen und so weiter. Nur vielleicht ist es einfach der Zeit geschuldet gewesen. Und Merkel heute wäre vielleicht die Herausforderung gewesen, ich muss mal an dieses Live-Leute-Interview denken, wo irgendwelche Leute auf die Idee kommen, können wir schicken, mal das junge Internet pack, so zum Interview und sie pariert das dann alles so rechts und links, dass sie dann am Ende auch sagt, ja, so ein paar Fragen hätten schon kommen können, so. Also ein paar Herausforderungen wären schon möglich gewesen. Vielleicht wäre Merz einfach der Kanzler gewesen, für die 16 Jahre.
Ja.
Wegverwalten, Partys veranstalten, wie auch immer, ein bisschen Bereicherung. Und jetzt bräuchten wir eigentlich so jemanden wie Merkel, der mal so ganz nüchtern in die Sachen einfach. Also wie auch immer, dieses Buch ist sehr gut für sowas.
Gut, worüber wir gleich noch anders lesen und so weiter, sagen wir, vorher gucken wir Clips, wir hören Clips.
Ja. Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von Procon. Was ist Procon? Procon ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften. Da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland. Und Procon ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es Procon in Deutschland, Polen, Finnland und Spanien. Procon setzt auf Wind-Onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethan. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dieses Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an Procon, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen, die 40.000 Mitglieder. Egal, wie viel man reinbringt. Die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus. Aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken Procon sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von drei bis fünf Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu Procon in unseren Show Notes, also greift mal in eure Hosentasche. Du fragtest mich, ob ich noch was hätte, was man heute spielen könnte. Ich sagte, nichts drängt sich auf. Dann sagtest du, du hast aber auch nichts. Dann habe ich gesagt, dann Gabor Steingart bei Paul Ronsheimer.
Ja, Gabor Steingart, früher Chefredakteur des Handelsplatzes, jetzt auf einem Dampfer mit Springer an Bord unterwegs, um wieder Vernunft in Wirtschaft und Politik zu bringen. Sein Morning Briefing ist unglaublich beliebt, seine Podcasts auch. Und er hat wieder mal ein Buch geschrieben, das davon handelt, dass Deutschland den Bach runtergeht. Und in gewisser Weise haben wir ja auch schon diese These mal bestätigt. Also, die Rezession ist da und sie darf nicht geleugnet werden. Aber Gabor Steingart hat da einen ganz anderen Ansatz, woran es denn liegt. Und er glaubt jetzt alles erklären zu können. Ich finde auch wunderbar, dass Rondsheimer ihn so ankündigt, als hätte er da einen der versiertesten Gesprächspartner in Sachen deutsche Wirtschaftspolitik.
Niemand kennt so viele wie Gabor Steingart. Und das ist ja das Auskunftsersuchen, was man sich einholt. Wer kennt die Chefs?
Ja.
So. Und dann ist ja alles, er kennt die Chefs. Okay, dann ist alles gut. Ist ja auch ein bisschen Märzerfolgsrezept. Wir haben das letzte Mal Ferdinand von Schirach-Clips, auch von Rondsheimer gehört. Ferdinand von Schirach, möchte ich noch mal in Erinnerung rufen, ist aufgefallen durch eine Idee zu sagen, ein Kanzler bitte sieben Jahre und drei politische Freischüsse, Gesetze, die einfach jahrelang gelten, einfach weil der Kanzler das wollte. Und jetzt könnten wir sagen, wow, das ist so extrem, das ist eine Abkehr vom Parlamentarismus, das ist nicht das, was wir wollen. Oder aber man könnte sagen, wow, das ist ja ein ganz zurückhaltender, aber mutiger Vorschlag, den Deutschland jetzt braucht. Und dann im Hinterkopf die nächste Frage, wie würde das klingen, wenn man das formuliert hätte, ohne dass man noch mal darauf verweist, dass man ja Schirach heißt? Und das hören wir jetzt bei Gabor Steingart, ich möchte es an teasern. Wie kommt so eine Idee rüber, wenn man keine Rücksicht auf eigene Familienverantwortung, Holocaust, mit Hitler bekannt und was auch immer haben muss? Also wir fangen aber an bei Bildung. Wir hören nachher, wir lesen nachher Stellen von Milanovic, bei dem Bildung noch mal thematisiert wird, auf eine Art und Weise, wie wir sagen, vielleicht sollte man es doch nicht immer so zur Seite schieben.
Es gibt da eine irre Zahl. Da geht es einmal um 10 Millionen Dollar Unterschied. 10 Millionen Dollar Unterschied Bildung.
Ich werde das nachher auch mit meinem Familienbuch nochmal verknüpfen. Ich nenne ja da auch Zahlen. Nur er nennt keine Zahlen, die er sich wünscht, sondern Zahlen von Geldern, die wirklich fließen. Pro Kopf Kind.
10 Millionen Dollar.
So, also die Bildung.
Wir sind auf einem falschen System. Die Politiker kümmern sich um Bildung, aber sie hat keinen Zweck, diese Bildung. Sie hat keinen ökonomischen Zweck. Deutschland steigt auch ab, weil andere sich an einen ökonomischen Zweck gegeben haben und haben gesagt, vor der Fabrik kommt, ach was denn, die Bildung. Das ist ja der Weg, der Weg zu allem, was danach kommt. Und wenn die Bildung auf dem falschen Ding ist, dann haben wir unfassbar viele Geisteswissenschaftler und keine Erfindungen.
Das ist das Problem. Wir haben nur noch Geisteswissenschaftler, die alle nicht mehr arbeiten können.
Die Bildung ist auf dem falschen Dings. Das beiten wir mal alles im Hinterkopf. Wir bauen jetzt hier langsam das Puzzle zusammen, wie er sich Deutschland und die Zukunft vorstellt.
Economy first war kein Slogan, sondern das war die gelebte Praxis aller Haushalte. Es wurde einfach gearbeitet. Freizeit wurde als Belohnung von Arbeit gesehen und nicht als Ersatz. Heute ist für viele Freizeit der Ersatz für Arbeit.
Die Freizeit. Als Ersatz für Arbeit, Erholung, wie auch immer. Er sagt, wir sollen mehr Bildung machen. Ist Bildung aber schon Arbeit?
Das ist die Frage.
Er möchte jetzt, dass wir mehr arbeiten.
Und instrumentelle Bildung, die er nur darauf ausgelegt ist, kann ich damit das BEP steigern.
Er möchte, dass wir klüger arbeiten und das schaffen wir, indem wir besser ausgebildet sind. Das passt aber nicht ganz zusammen bei ihm.
Was schätzt du, wie viel Arbeitszeit ein Akademiker, männlich, in seinem Leben, also wie viel Zeit seines Lebens er am Arbeitsplatz verbringt, schätzt du?
So, jetzt hören wir, dass Ronzheimer diese Frage erst nicht versteht, was auch bedeutet, hier saßen wieder Leute zusammen, die ein Sachbuch konzipiert haben, die meinten, wir brauchen irgendwie eine harte Zahl, irgendetwas ganz Imposantes. Ja, Gabor, aber das ist ganz schwierig zu argumentieren. Das macht auch gar keinen Sinn. Es ist nicht ohne Grund, dass wir diese Zahl so noch nie gehört haben. Sie ist vielleicht ein bisschen doof, so, ja. Aber Gabor, reite drauf rum.
Wir haben das für das Buch ausgerechnet. Schlaf und alles zählt jetzt mit dazu, oder musst du abreden?
Wir sagen pro Woche, kann ich sagen.
Nein, für dein Leben.
Mein Leben, für dein Leben. Wie viel schlechte Mathe ist schon immer gewesen, Gabor.
Einfach nur ein Gefühl. Das ist ja ein Gefühl. Wie viel deines Lebens? Die Kindheit schon mal nicht, Rente schon mal nicht, Wochenende schon mal nicht.
Drittel meines Lebens?
Zehn Prozent.
Was ist das für eine Zahl?
Das ist eine Zahl, wie man könnte auch das Durchschnittsgewicht ausrechnen. Dann könnten alle Arbeiter oder so. Das ist völlig irrsinnig.
Also ich sehe ja das jetzt immer. Sagen wir mal, wir lesen es jetzt möglichst konstruktiv. Wie viel Lebenszeit verbringen wir mit Arbeit, Erwerbsarbeit? Ich würde jetzt sagen, die Definition ist für jemand anderen nicht für uns selbst. Das ist ja so die unausgesprochene Wahrheit da drin. Zehn Prozent. Ich mache ja häufiger diese Pointe, wer mehr bib will, könnte auch abseits des Kalendereffekts darauf setzen, dass vielleicht die Bahn pünktlich kommt. Dann fallen schon mal ein paar Reisetage, die eingeplant werden müssen, raus. Also da würde ich jetzt sagen, lass uns doch mal jede Lebenszeit durchrechnen. Also dass man nicht nur arbeitet, sondern auch den ganzen anderen Kram. Wir können mal feststellen, wie wenig eigentlich so übrig bleibt. Also so im Heck lünschen dieses eine Leben.
Genau, also Handwerker könnten in NRW sicherlich pro Tag einen Auftrag mehr annehmen, wenn sie nicht laufend im Stau stünden. Und ich könnte auch sehr viel mehr machen, wenn ich nicht jetzt wie vergangene Woche dreimal hintereinander knapp zwei Stunden Verspätung gehabt hätte.
Genau, also einfach mal solche Sachen dann wirklich durchbilanzieren.
Wir haben die Kindheit sehr lang gemacht mit der Bildung.
Ja, das ist das, was du gerade wolltest, dass wir gute Bildung machen.
Aber bitte nur instrumentelle Bildung. Das heißt aber auch, alle, die jetzt nicht gebraucht werden in der akademischen Kaste oder für irgendwelche Facharbeiten, wo man ein Studium benötigt, die sollen möglichst ganz früh wieder arbeiten. Also könnte man nicht sagen, warum, also er traut sich das natürlich nicht zu sagen, aber er könnte eigentlich sagen, könnte man nicht auch einfache Tätigkeiten ab dem 12. Lebensjahr machen.
Ja, genau.
Das wäre nämlich dann die Idee. Und sie beglückwünschen sich ja noch gegenseitig dabei, den Clip hast du jetzt nicht, wie die sie als High-Performer bestimmt bei 15 Prozent sind mit dem Arbeiten. Dabei sind sie ja überhaupt nicht produktiv. Also wir in dem Sinne auch nicht. Ja, wir nehmen Podcasts auf. Aber sie tun ja gar nichts für dieses BIP, wo sie die ganze Zeit von reden im Sinne von Industriearbeit oder so. Das ist ja alles nicht da.
Genau, da kommen wir eh gleich drauf nochmal.
Sie haben ja ihr Leben auch nur mit Schwätzen verbracht.
Was ist die Definition von Arbeit?
Ja.
Also befördern und bewirten. Und zwar auf der passiven Seite, dass man das erfährt als Komfort, ist keine Arbeit. Ja. Das muss man ganz deutlich sagen. Ich sehe sehr viele Bundespolitiker, bei denen immer rumgejammert wird, wie voll ihr Terminkalender ist. Aber ehrlich gesagt, es ist deren Hobby.
Markus Söder hat 400 Millionen auf dem Konto. Der geht doch nicht morgens zur Erwerbsarbeit, sondern das ist doch ein ganz klares Hobby und das Lustprinzip für sein Ego, dass da einfach ausgelebt wird. Und zwar ein ganzes Leben lang.
Ja. Ja, ja. 100 Empfänge pro Woche. Das ist einfach toll. Immer wieder der König. Und es gibt Applaus.
Diese anstrengende Arbeit, dass der Saal bereitet wird, das Licht eingeschaltet, das Buffet. Und damit der Herr Söder kommt. Und seine Arbeit dort verrichtet.
Ja.
Gut. Wir hören nochmal diesen Einstieg, diesen Clip.
Langgemacht mit der Bildung, das Renten.
Wir haben die Kindheit langgemacht mit der Bildung.
Langgemacht mit der Bildung, das Renten-Ding ist.
So, er rechnet jetzt diesen Teil, man studiert Physik. Und danach ein Ingenieur zu sein, ist für ihn einfach eine Kindheit.
Ja. Die wir langgemacht haben.
Die langgemachte Kindheit.
Auch bedauernd länger. Renten, wir haben die Kindheit sehr langgemacht mit der Bildung. Das Renten-Ding ist auch das Rentending bedauernd länger. Dazwischen haben wir verkürzt 30 Urlaubstage. Zwei Tage sind sowieso frei. Samstags, Sonntag 19 Krankentage im Durchschnitt. 30 Urlaubstage, 19 Krankentage. Wir haben 52 Wochen, zwei Tage, 104 Tage sind Wochenende. Überleg mal, was von den 365 Tagen überhaupt bleibt.
Ja, 0,1% Gabor. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Im Prinzip ist alles dicht draußen, keiner geht mehr arbeiten.
Er baut uns jetzt eine Metapher.
So, also ein solches Missverhältnis zwischen denen, die Wohlstand erzeugen und denen, die Wohlstand verkonsumieren. Ich unterscheide das in Kern und Kruste, produktive Kern eines Landes. Und auf der Kruste sitzen die Rentner, die Bürgergeldempfänger, die Kinder, auch Hausbrauen. Alle, die Wohlstand von anderen erzeugt, konsumieren und andere, die ihn produzieren, sitzen im Kern.
Kruste und Kern.
Ganz einfach.
Muss man das noch kommentieren?
Unser versiertester Wirtschaftsjournalist.
Dann ein Wort zur Bürokratie.
Also ich glaube, die Unternehmer und Unternehmerinnen würden gerne richtig loslegen. Die müssen entfesselt werden. Die haben keinen Bock, einfach Zettel auszufüllen für die Bürokratie.
Ja, die müssen einfach alle entfesselt werden. Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, sagt er jetzt.
Also der Staat macht es denen schwer. Ich glaube, die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, glaube ich.
Wir wissen ja, wie die Reallöhne sich entwickelt haben. Komischerweise hatten wir alle Lust auf Wohlstand, aber es ist nicht angekommen.
Er hat auch gerade selber definiert, wie er sich das vorstellt. Urlaubsstage weg, Lebensarbeitszeit hoch. Wo genau passt jetzt hier die Wohlstandsdefinition ein?
Du kannst dann sagen, mit nur noch 15 Urlaubstagen und einem Renteneintrittsalter von 75 Jahren. Aber unser BIP ist richtig nach oben gegangen. Ich habe zwar davon nichts abbekommen, aber ich habe dem BIP alles gegeben, was ich habe.
Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand.
Wessen Wohlstand? Das ist der Wohlstand derer, die sich Arbeitskraft kaufen können. Und diese Arbeitskräfte sollen bitte jetzt länger arbeiten. Das ist wirklich kapitalistische Propaganda in Reihenform. Das ist ja so von Marx und Engels in der Analyse abgeschrieben, aber dann als Gebrauchsanweisung gewendet, dass man es gar nicht fassen kann.
Das ist nämlich mein Punkt. Das sind im Grunde Marxisten nur auf der falschen Seite und sie haben es nicht gelesen. Aber die Fremdzuschreibung, wie schon bei Lindemann, wenn man einfach überall nur noch Reservarmee sieht und so und in diesem Begriff Struktur denkt, ist man einfach ein Marxist. Das muss man ihm schon nur halt nicht in diesem...
Na ja, beziehungsweise es bestätigt sich, wie einmal mehr des Marx richtig lag.
Genau. Gabor Steingart ist sehr klug, aber die SPD, dafür reicht sie nicht, um das zu verstehen.
Gerhard Schröder, die haben sich Gedanken gemacht, wie kriege ich das da unten ein bisschen heißer im Kern, dass das Land Wohlstand hat. Das ist mir unverständlich tatsächlich, weil die Partei wird ja dafür gar nicht belohnt. Sie schrumpft die ganze Zeit. Also mit dem Kern, wo die Facharbeiter ja zu Hause sind, also ihre Wähler, diese Kernschrumpfung ist eine Schrumpfung auch der SPD.
Diese Facharbeiter hat die SPD mit der Agenda 2010 geschwächt, deshalb, weil die Tarifbindung aufgehoben wurde, weil man jetzt an den Werkbänken der Facharbeiter Leute hat, die von irgendwelchen Zeitarbeitsfirmen da kommen und zu sehr viel schlechteren Bedingungen dort sind, als die Facharbeiter, die noch die alten Verträge haben. Die SPD hat genau diesen Kern zerstört.
Man könnte auch im Milanovic-Sinne kurz einfach nachfragen, Gabor, hast du dir den Strukturwandel der Wirtschaft angeschaut, die letzten 40 Jahre, als die SPD so verlor? Wo sind die Industriefacharbeiter, die damals noch Kohle, Fabrik und so weiter? Also es ist halt auch ein bisschen Zeitgeist.
Und deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht, wie dumm kann man sein, wie dumm kann man sein, das für klug zu halten, immer diese Kruste zu erweitern und anderen Menschen Energie abzuzapfen, Erbschaftsfeuer, immer noch eine Idee, wie man irgend wem was neckt. Du weißt, wo der Spitzensteuersatz ist. Der ist mitten da, wo der Facharbeiter sein Gehalt hat. Der ist mitten da. Also wer kommt auf die Idee, seine Kernwähler dauernd zu massakrieren? Die Industriearbeiter werden auf diese Art gekillt in Deutschland.
Ihr kommt auf die Idee, weil ihr ja nicht die höheren Einkommen stärker besteuern wollt, weil ihr keine Erbschaftssteuer wollt, weil ihr keine Vermögensteuer wollt, dann kann man nur dort in der arbeitenden Bevölkerung eine große Umverteilung vornehmen. Und tatsächlich trifft das dann die Leute, die, sagen wir, 70.000, 80.000 im Jahr verdienen, eigentlich am stärksten. Das ist aber genau die Klasse, die einen Gabor Steingart nicht vertritt. Denn er vertritt ja die Kapitalseite, die sagt, ich kann hier nichts mehr machen, ich brauche eher eine Steuersenkung. Mach das mal mit denen Leuten, die arbeiten gehen. Die sollen mal einen ordentlichen Steuersatz zahlen.
Also, Hans Eichel mal eingeklammert hier, aber das, was er beschreibt, ist eben auch Theo Weigl und Wolfgang Schäuble.
Ja, ganz klar.
Das hat jetzt so viel mit SPD gar nichts zu tun.
Aber gut.
Steingart findet Sozialstaat nicht ganz so gut.
Wenn ich das noch gerade anführen darf, das war ja so interessant, dass die CDU ja immer rumlief und sagte, wir müssen den Solidaritätszuschlag für alle streichen. Also da auch für die oberen zehn Einkommensprozent. Und das haben sie ja nicht gemacht. Warum können sie das nicht machen? Denn man kann darüber streiten, ob man das machen sollte oder nicht. Ich bin nicht dafür, aber selbst wenn man jetzt dafür wäre, muss man sich ja fragen, was geschieht dann? Wo kommt das Geld sonst her? Und da man sich genau nicht herantraut an das wirkliche Kapital, kann man in der Arbeitenbevölkerung selbst eine solche kleine Erleichterung für die ohnehin Gutverdienenden nicht durchsetzen. Man ist völlig gebunden. Man hat sich die Hände gebunden aufgrund von Austeritätspolitik und einer Steuerpolitik, die sagt, niemals werden wir die reichen, niemals die Vermögen, niemals die Erbschaften stärker besteuern. Dann kann man innerhalb der Arbeiterschaft auch nicht mehr viel umverteilen.
Ist im Grunde ein Lockdown, der hier stattfindet?
Nur an den Posten in der Tat, da hast du ja recht, wenn die Leute sagen, ich will eigentlich die Viertagewoche und ich möchte bei der Rente doch eher noch eine Schippe drauf. Wenn das die Mehrheitsmeinung ist, dann hat auch Friedrich Merz niemand eine Chance.
So, also Gabor, wie jetzt? Haben die Deutschen Bock auf Wohlstand oder haben sie Bock auf ganz viel Arbeit und eben keinen Wohlstand? Ich blicke noch nicht ganz durch.
Könnte dann vielleicht auch mein Moderator eine kluge Frage stellen?
Das wäre natürlich... Also Ronzheimer ist nicht ganz so schlecht in dem Gespräch hinten raus, wenn es um die AfD geht, kommen wir gleich zu. Jetzt erstmal alles kürzen.
Natürlich wollen die Leute nicht gerne in Rentenkürzungen.
Nee, die haben ja Bock auf Wohlstand. Klar haben die dann keinen Bock auf Rentenkürzungen.
Eigentlich lief doch jetzt alles darauf hinaus, dass Gabor Steingart sagen würde, wir müssen unbedingt die Rente kürzen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Aber dann würde er sich wahrscheinlich mit seiner eigenen Hörerschaft anlegen und Leserschaft.
Das weiß ich nicht, weil es könnte sein, dass ihm Leute sagen, also wir haben Auswertungen unserer Zahlen gesehen, Rentner hören uns nicht. Es ist die arbeitende Bevölkerung, die morgens nicht viel Zeit hat und schnell zur Arbeit und sich dann nochmal kurz indoktriniert.
Aber eigentlich würde es jetzt auf eine Rentenkürzung hinauslaufen, ja, in seiner Argumentation.
Ja, also das war unmissverständlich.
Natürlich wollen die Leute nicht gerne eine Rentenkürzung. Das wäre auch gar nicht meine Empfehlung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach so, wirklich. Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, aber eigentlich sollte man mal die Renten kürzen, aber das wäre auch gar nicht meine Empfehlung, aber das sollte man trotzdem machen.
Ping-Pong. Ich weiß, dass die Renten im unteren Drittel und das in Millionen, schon jetzt nicht reichen. Also insofern Vorsicht sozusagen, nicht Erkenntnisse zu einer Ideologie verdichten und dann sagen, und jetzt die Kürzung für alle. Das ist es nicht. Insofern ist die Rente schon ein super defiziles Thema.
So, und erst jetzt geht dieses Interview richtig los. Also die Rente ist ein ganz defiziles Thema. Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, aber hohe Renten können wir auf gar keinen Fall machen. Also sollte man irgendwie, aber es wäre jetzt nicht meine Empfehlung, aber März muss mal und so. Jetzt kommt seine alternative Idee, die ist so genial, man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht heraus. Wir werden das gleich um die Daumen mal so durchrechnen, was das so insgesamt bedeutet.
Unser Umlagesystem, du zahlst für deine Eltern und unsere Kinder zahlen für uns, so es Kinder gibt. Und that's it, da wird nichts verzinst. Das Geld wird weiter gereicht, ich sage mal, wie einer afrikanischen Großfamilie von der Hand in den Mund. Und zwar die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Also es ist ihm jetzt noch eingefallen, dass er das mal besser nicht auf die Gegenwart bezieht, nicht, dass er da noch was an...
Die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts. In welchem Geschichtsbuch muss ich nachlesen um etwas über die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts? Also was ist das bitte für eine Empirie?
Aber das wollte sich jetzt mal schnell retten, das war früher, also nicht, dass er mir jetzt Rassismus hier unterstellen wollte.
Das ist des 19. Jahrhunderts, Afrika ist fortschrittlicher als wir.
Afrika des 19. Jahrhunderts, die Großfamilie dort war fortschrittlicher als wir, weil wir haben ein Rentenumlage-System.
Also dieses Umlageverfahren 0, das kann gar nichts werden, bei Kinderlosigkeit verbreitet. Demografischer Faktor ist ein anderes Wort für Kinderlosigkeit.
Demografischer Faktor ist ein anderes Wort für Kinderlosigkeit.
So und deswegen muss man um, das System muss um. Am Kapitalmarkt gibt es 8% jedes Jahr. Seit Gründung des DAX jedes Jahr. Es gibt mal einen DIP, dann sind es sechs, im nächsten zwölf. 8% ist die Durchschnittsrentite.
So, der DAX macht ja jedes Jahr 8%. Also sollten wir das Geld, das wir jetzt in die Rentenkasse einzahlen, einfach dorthin bleiben. Das Problem ist, da ja das Umlagesystem zweifach verrechnet wird, also Einzahlung, Auszahlung, wo kommt dann das Geld für die Auszahlung her? Das haben wir dann nicht mehr. Das heißt, für die Jungen gehen wir jetzt in den DAX und für die Alten haben wir leider keinen Auszahlungsbetrag mehr. Dass wir für die Alten dann kein Geld mehr haben, blenden wir jetzt mal aus, weil das ist einfach scheuert. Aber der DAX ist um 8% gewachsen die letzten Jahre. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, aber ich höre immer so Nachrichten wie, ein amerikanisches Unternehmen wie Nvidia oder so ist mehr wert als der ganze DAX. Das heißt, der DAX ist wahrscheinlich so knapp unter halb 5 Billionen. Keine Ahnung. Man muss es jetzt gar nicht genau nehmen. Wir zahlen jedes Jahr 350 Milliarden Rente aus und 250 Milliarden ins Umlagesystem ein. Also dann kommen ja 100 Milliarden Staatsgeld dazu, Bundesgeld. Das heißt, diese 250 Milliarden möchte er jetzt pro Jahr in den DAX zahlen. Also wer soll das Geld entgegennehmen? Sagen wir dann, ja, also alle vier Jahre sind die DAX-Konzerne einfach eine Billion Mehrwert, weil wir ja jedes Jahr 250 Milliarden eingezahlt haben. Und das über 30 Jahre. Also die DAX-Konzerne sind jetzt einfach 10 Billionen Euro Mehrwert. Weil wir das ja einzahlen, das Geld.
Ja, wir schaffen einfach Reichtum dadurch.
Und jetzt will ich sagen, ich bin ja kein Ökonom, sondern du, Gabor. Aber wie genau ist das? Also sollten wir dann feierliche Texte bei einem Wall Street Journal anmelden und sagen, ja, ganz wundersamerweise ist der DAX dreimal so viel wert wie eure teuren Unternehmen. Ihr dachtet immer, das sei umgedreht. Aber nein, denn ja.
Und dann bleibt natürlich auch diese enorme Rendite. Und könnte diese enorme Rendite vielleicht auch damit zusammenhängen, dass es den Arbeitern schon so schlecht geht, dass man die Löhne eben nicht erhöht hat, sondern tatsächlich die Profite steigern konnte. Nämlich dann steigert man ja die Aktienkurse. Aktienkurse sind ja noch nie gestiegen, weil man die Arbeiter besser bezahlt hat.
Also das sind ganz merkwürdige Fantasien, die man hier hat.
Man fragt sich auch, warum geht man dann überhaupt noch arbeiten? Können wir nicht einfach nur noch Börsianer alle sein?
Genau. Weil das größte Problem der Superreichen, das ist ja selten Thema, die wissen nicht wohin mit dem Geld. Wenn jetzt Deutschland pro Jahr noch 250 Milliarden zusätzlich in diesen Markt der Asian-Orientierungslos geht, geht man dann in Immobilienfonds, weil die DAX-Konzerne nicht genug Volumen haben. Zum Beispiel. Wir machen eine Altersvorsorge, die dazu führt, dass die deutschen Städte, wenn man mal die Mietfläche einfach durchkalkuliert, pro Jahr um 250 Milliarden im Wert steigt. Das muss ja auch verrechnet werden. Ich verstehe, es ist einfach völlig absurd, solche Sachen.
Also es geht natürlich nur auf eine Weise. Wenn man das wirklich mal auf das Inland denkt, dann können wir das mit einem ganz simplen Beispiel machen. Also ich kaufe mir eine Netflix-Aktie und dann sage ich toll, der Wert ist gestiegen, der Netflix-Aktie. Und dann schaue ich bei Netflix rein und bekomme dort angezeigt, ihr Abo ist jetzt 5 Euro teurer. Und da gibt es einen Zusammenhang. Und dann habe ich 5 Euro da mehr zu zahlen für Netflix und habe 5 Euro bei der Aktie. Und genauso wäre das natürlich bei Mieten. Die Mieten werden entsprechend die Konzerne dann noch mehr haben, werden die Mieten also steigern. Aber ich bekomme dann eine Rendite wieder raus. Also das führt zu nichts. Das einzige, was also geht und was natürlich dann immer die Länder da machen, die viel Erdöl haben und dann diese Fonds auflegen, man investiert irgendwo im Ausland und hofft, dass da so viel Wirtschaftswachstum ist, dass man davon dann was abschöpferweise ist. Natürlich der Wunsch, dass andere arbeiten für einen.
Andere müssen das dann hinkriegen.
Ja und dass das nicht für die Gesamtgesellschaft möglich ist, zumal auch diese Rechnungen ja in dieser Weise nicht stimmen, wie ihr das dann einfach so sagt, wir gehen da mal alle rein.
Das ist einfach gar nichts. Also wir hören jetzt mal das Resultat aus dieser Überlegung, die er da anführt. Und wir überlegen mal gleichzeitig, was bedeutet das für die Kosten derjenigen, die plötzlich von diesem neuen Rentenregen, den er da verspricht, profitieren.
Es gibt gar keine Alternative, Paul. Ich sag dir, es wird kommen. Nicht der Einzelne. Ich will nicht Lieschen Müller jetzt an die Börse schicken morgens.
Ja, das kann die ja gar nicht, weißt du.
Statt auf dem Wochenmarkt an die Börse. Funktioniert nicht. Aber ein Staatsfonds. Diese gigantische Umverteilungsmaschinerie der Rente. Das Geld genommen. Nicht 0,0 Verzinsung, sondern das an der Börse. Acht Prozent. Und dann wird tatsächlich und das klingt jetzt unseriös und es trotzdem war, jeder heute 25, 28-Jährige, wenn wir das machen würden, ist nachher Millionär.
So, wenn jeder Millionär ist und Wirtschaft hat immer ganz viel mit Relation zueinander zu tun, dann kostet auch deine Miete einfach eine Million Euro im Jahr. Ja. Sonst geht das gar nicht auf. Dann kann zwar jeder Vermieter von sich sagen, ich bin jetzt Milliardär, aber das nützt ja gar nichts.
Nein. Also er sagt die ganze Zeit, ja die Produktivität muss gesteigert werden. Und jetzt will er aber einfach nur so ein Rentiersystem haben, aus dem jeder jetzt was bezieht ja, man könnte auch den Vorschlag machen.
Das stimmt, wir sind ganz weit weg von Produktivität gerade.
Ja, man könnte auch den Vorschlag machen, warum werden wir nicht eigentlich alle Vermieter? Und vermieten, ich werde dein Vermieter, du wirst mein Vermieter, dann können wir doch immer Geld hin und her tauschen, dann ist doch jeder reich. Ach nee, ist ja gar nicht.
Hatte nicht irgendwer gesagt, wir können uns nicht alle nur noch die Haare schneiden?
Ja.
So, er ist natürlich jetzt so klug, dass er auch die Klugheit anderen gibt, und zwar nicht nur uns Podcast-Hörern.
Frau Merkel hat es ja versucht und ich beschreibe das auch in dem Buch. Ich hatte vor, weiß nicht, 2004 ein Buch geschrieben, Deutschland, der Abstieg eines Superstars. Sie war Oppositionsführerin auf den letzten Tagen. Sie lud mich ein, sagte Steingart, ich will was verändern. Ich war beim Spiegel damals. Erzählen Sie mir, ich will das wissen. Und sie hat mitgeschrieben, wir haben anderthalb, zwei Stunden. Sie wird Kanzlerin. Sie lädt mich wieder ein. Steingart, ich mein's ernst. Ich sollte fünf Leute mitbringen, fünf Kronzeugen, wie es gehen kann. Ich habe mitgebracht, damals. Sie war gerade Kanzlerin.
Ist ja auch irgendwie erschreckend, dass Merkel sich überhaupt darauf einlässt, oder?
Na, das auch. So, Merkel, bitte dich als jungen Gabor Steingart, bitte bringen Sie die Weisheit mit. Wen bringst du mit? Fünf Leute sollte sie ja mitbringen. Wir hören jetzt die Liste. Es ist wirklich...
Matthias Döpfner, der dich schon damals kannte und schätzte. Ich habe mitgebracht Bert Rührup vom Rate der Weisen. Ich habe einen Investmentbanker aus London, David Marge, mitgebracht. Rainer Neske aus dem Vorstand der Deutschen Bank, heute Chef der Landesbank Baden-Württemberg und noch jemanden.
Schön.
Rührup, Döpfner, ein Typ aus der London City, City of London und ein deutscher Marktvorstand.
Ja.
Ist doch ganz ausgewogen, denke ich.
Das ist wirklich. Aber sie hat ja dann nicht auf ihn gehört.
Ja, also das muss man gerade in den Kontext setzen. Es gab die Agenda 2010 und dann wollte ja Merkel noch härter da rein. Sie wollte ja wirklich den Sozialstaat kurz und klein schlagen. Und da gab es ja dann auch Rebellionen aus der christlichen, aus der sozial-christlichen Warte da, aus der Union, vor allem auch aus der CSU. Da ist sie also böse mit hingefallen und dann hat sie das nicht mehr angefasst, das Thema. Und das wirft Steingart ihr bis heute vor.
Und wir wissen ja, Döpfner und so, wie verantwortungsvoll sie auch mit dem deutschen Wohlstand umgehen. Da wird einfach mal eine Milliarde so gar nicht verzollt an der Altersgrenze oder an der Schenkungsgrenze. Sein Urteil heute über Merkel, wo sie doch nicht auf ihn hörte.
Angela Merkel ist eine intellektuelle, eine wohltemperierte, nachdenkliche Frau. Aber in dieser Phase der Geschichte wäre jemand, der Mut gehabt hätte, ich sage nicht tollkühn, aber doch in die Richtung, das, was Gerhard Schröder eben riskiert hat. Oh, sie hat einfach nichts riskiert.
Ja, sie hat es einfach nicht riskiert, den Leuten, die gerade erfahren haben, dass ihr Wohlstand jetzt doch nur noch so ein Jahr Arbeitslosigkeit aushält, denen auch noch zu sagen, dass es im Alter dann auch nichts gibt. Hat sie sich nicht getraut, wo die Deutschen auch so viel Bock auf Wohlstand haben? So, jetzt kommen wir zu diesem Schirach-Ding. Also Schirach sagt, ich wähle einen starken Kanzler. Sieben Jahre, drei Freischussgesetze. Aber ich sage es nur vorsichtig, weil mein Name ist Schirach. Gabor Steingart heißt Steingart. Unverfänglich. Kann er so richtig reinbuttern.
Du nennst in deinem Buch die deutsche Verfassungskonstruktion einen, Zitat, deutschen Defekt und schreibst dazu, wir seien das wahrscheinlich langsamste Staatswesen in der westlichen Welt, wenig sprunghaft, frei von Exzessen, gründlich in jeder Hinsicht, auch in der, dass wir den Weg nach unten seit Jahrzehnten unbeirrt weitergehen. Was genau ist dieser deutsche Defekt?
Ja, das ist der Antiführerstaat. Also nach Hitler haben die Alliierten, der parlamentarische Rat, einen Staat geschaffen, der eine Prämisse hatte, nie wieder Krieg und nie wieder einen Führer.
Das ist jetzt genau das Thema von Stefan Kühl eigentlich. Ja, also nur halt falsch verstanden.
Genau, genau falsch verstanden. Also die ganze Idee, dass Deutschland nach dem Krieg so ein einzigartiges Wirtschaftssachstum hingelegt hat, kam durch diese Bürokratie. Dass einfach alle wussten, was sie jetzt zu tun haben und keiner über die Strenge schlug und sagte, aber das ist doch eine gute Idee, die ich gerade vorgeschlagen habe. Können sie nicht einfach machen? Nee, wir gucken noch mal im Handbuch nach, ob das passt. So, also Bürokratie hat uns nicht die Freiheit von Superreichen und Zampanos. Wir sind eben nicht als Zampano-Business aus dem Dritten Reich rausgekommen, sondern wir haben genau das Gegenteil versucht. Und das ist bis heute eigentlich weltweit bewundert.
Also die ganze Ingenieurskunst, die bewundert wird, beruht nur darauf, dass man sich an diese Regeln gehalten hat, beziehungsweise neue Regeln geschaffen hat. Aber das waren nicht irgendwelche Basteleien, wo man einfach geguckt hat, schauen wir mal, ob das Auto auch fährt, sondern man hat versucht, so verlässlich wie möglich zu produzieren. Deshalb sind ja die deutschen Premium-Autos in der Welt so beliebt, weil sie diese enorme Verlässlichkeit haben. Das bringt natürlich eine gewisse Inflexibilität mit sich, aber das ist ja zugleich auch Garant dafür, dass diese Autos funktionieren.
Genau. Und eigentlich ist das Argument auch nicht schwer zu verstehen. Wenn die Bahn so fährt, wie sie im Fahrplan steht, weil das die Regeln für alle sind, dann funktioniert es. Und wenn wir einen Fahrplan haben, aber keiner hält sich dran, dann funktioniert es halt nicht. Ja. Und wenn es daran liegt, dass man den Fahrplan gar nicht einhalten kann, selbst wenn man will, weil Geld fehlt, dann weiß man genau, wo man jetzt ansetzen müsste eigentlich.
Bei Geld und nicht bei den Regeln.
Aber so wie der Schirach wird hier einfach, oder meint es wirklich ernst, er möchte jetzt wieder das Führerprinzip.
Dieser Anti-Führer-Staat, ich nenne das einen deutschen Defekt, das ist die Hitlerzeit, die wir mit uns mitfleppen sozusagen. Die Hitlerzeit verewigt sich in unseren Verwaltungsroutinen der Entschleunigung. Jeder darf klagen, wir sind superdemokratisch und alles.
Ja.
Die Deutschen haben Wohlstand. Doch nicht. Demokratie, schöne, gute. Es wird alles abgeräumt hier. Ja. Das sind wirklich... Also diese, vielleicht sollte man es... Kann jemand ein Sachbuch schreiben über diese Leute? Also Schirach, Gabor Steingart, natürlich auch so ein bisschen Thomas Gottschalk. Kann man so ein bisschen schreiben. Warum wird der ausgelacht und die anderen nicht? Also offene Frage. Man nennt es dann, also Titel ist Die Abräumer. Ja. Die einfach, die sehen den Tisch vor sich, das ist auch reichlich gedeckt, drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt. Einmal abräumen bitte.
Alles weg, was hier irgendwie noch als, wir brauchen wieder den Führer. Dieses Rentensystem, ganz schlecht. Bürokratie, ganz schlecht. Demokratie, ganz schlecht. Führer, super. Das ist im Grunde Tenor dieser alten Männer, ja. Es ist unglaublich.
Wurde er unfallbewertet, Robert Habeck?
So, das ist witzig. Nachdem sie jetzt über den Führer und wie toll das doch war, als wir noch einen Führerstaat hatten. Das ist natürlich blöd, wenn du dir einen Führer wünschst und dann kommst du aber über demokratische Verfahren, so ein Robert Habeck ins Wirtschaftsministerium, ne? Das kannst du natürlich als, ich kenn mich ja auch aus, mit Wirtschaft, ich bin Gabor Steingart. Da musst du natürlich Worte elefanten.
Robert Habeck?
Naja, sag mal so, ich glaube, der ist ein fähiger Politiker und ein großer Denker sogar.
Sozialwissenschaftler wahrscheinlich.
Auch einer, der gut formulieren kann, aber der hätte nicht auf diesen Job gehört.
Also Wirtschaftsminister war falsch.
Auf jeden Fall, weil er das nicht verstanden hat.
Also anders als die Reiche, anders als der Peter Altmaier. Robert Habeck hat es einfach nicht verstanden.
Wirtschaft, glaube ich, ist genau wie Tanzen, also ich zum Beispiel.
Wirtschaft ist genau wie Tanzen, Herr Steingart.
Also ich zum Beispiel, ich kann nicht tanzen. Und ich glaube, obwohl ich in der Tanzschule war. Kannst du tanzen, Paul?
Ich habe es mal in der Tanzschule versucht, aber nicht.
Liebe deutschen Podcaster, müsst ihr immer kokettieren? Auf die Frage hin, kannst du tanzen, Paul? Kann man nicht einmal sagen, ja, ich werde mich für einen sehr guten Tänzer, ich bin vielleicht der Beste. Ich gehe da sehr gerne hin, ich mache das regelmäßig. Warum immer diese Kokettierscheiße? Ach, Mathe, da waren wir alle schlecht und so. Das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Also falls ihr von uns kein Kokettieren hört, werft es uns nicht vor. Wir sind einfach nur normale Menschen.
Ich kann nicht wirklich tanzen, nein.
Man muss das im Blut auch haben, ein bisschen das Rhythmusgefühl.
Ich bin aus Friesen.
Also die reden gerade über Wirtschaftspolitik, ja.
Ich bin jetzt so gespannt, was das mit der Wirtschaft zu tun hat.
Ein bisschen das Rhythmusgefühl.
Ich bin aus Friesen.
Ja, ich bin Berliner, Kreuzberg, also keine Ahnung. Also wir sind frech, wir Kreuzberg, wir können nicht tanzen und in Norddeutschland vielleicht auch Schunke geht.
Schunke, ja.
Aber dieses Rhythmusgefühl für Wirtschaft fehlt ihm. Und das muss man merken. Wenn man nicht tanzen kann, dann muss man nicht der erste auf der Tanzfläche sein, wie John Travolta. Und wenn man das Rhythmusgefühl für Wirtschaft nicht hat, dann sollte man diese Zone meiden.
Jetzt haben wir endlich die alles erklärende Argumentation bekommen, warum Habeck nicht erfolgreich war. Er hatte das Rhythmusgefühl nicht. Wer hätte das gedacht? Wir haben immer in den Zahlen gesucht, überlegt, war diese Sache mit Intel das Richtige? Hätte man stärker auf Infrastruktur gehen müssen? Nein, es lag einfach nur am Rhythmusgefühl. Und Peter Altmaier zum Beispiel, der ist bestimmt ein großer Tänzer und der hat ein Rhythmusgefühl.
Ja, das ist so schräg. Das kann man sich alles gar nicht vorstellen. Klar, da sitzen jetzt beide, die erklären uns über die Welt. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass sie alles wissen.
Eigentlich für eine Elitendämmerung, die wir jetzt hier seit ein paar Monaten begleiten, da ist ja nichts mehr da. Also ich wundere mich ja, wenn ich das hier höre und weiß, dass die Leute auf die gehört wird und die sich mit den wichtigen treffen, mich wundert ja, dass da draußen überhaupt irgendwas noch funktioniert. Also das scheint ja aufgrund der Bürokratie, aufgrund des Regelwerks alles so gut gefestigt zu sein, dass selbst diese Hainis das nicht zerstören können so einfach. Also ein Glück, man muss eigentlich jetzt mittlerweile froh sein um jede bürokratische Hürde, weil die alles einhegt, was die davor haben.
Ich stelle mir vor, Gabor Steingart würde dich aus dem Cockpit begrüßen und sagen, wir fliegen jetzt hier nach Hamburg, würde dich sofort freiwillig rausspringen, eine Schule leiten. Das würde alles überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren. Also wir haben Elitendämmerung, das sind Abräumer hier, das ist, man kann es sich alles, meine These ist ja immer, mir ist es früher aufgefallen, wenn Leute Rezension schreiben mussten, zu Büchern oder so, und sie haben es nicht ganz verstanden oder hatten auch nicht Lust, das Ganze zu Ende zu lesen, dann war das Urteil einfach immer so negativ, um sich so selbst behauptend noch zu dem Text zu verhalten und sich nicht geschlagen zu geben. Und dann hat man irgendeine Kritik erfunden einfach. Und so ist das hier auch. Diese Leute haben keine Ahnung von nichts, und wir hören gleich noch ganz schlimme Zitate von Gabor Steingart über Friedrich Merz. Die haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Das erinnert mich an diese Medienleute, die wohl mal so eine ganze Republik ausraste, dass man als Headliner noch irgendso einen Intendanten da hat. Und dann sitzen 100 Leute im Publikum, die alle jetzt gerade ein YouTube-Video hochladen oder irgendwas auf Instagram machen oder so. Und so nach 10 Minuten dämmert denen der Typ auf der Bühne, der uns gerade das Mediensystem erklärt, hat noch niemals das YouTube-Upload-Formular gesehen. Der weiß ja nicht, wie Instagram funktioniert. Der hat keine Ahnung von nichts. Der sitzt nun in irgendwelchen Redaktionskonferenzen immer rum und wirft am Ende noch mal so eine alles entscheidende Idee, bei der man sich aber vorher nicht einmüscht in Diskussionen. Ich entscheide hier, weil ich der Chef bin. Punkt. Wir färben rot. Wir haben es ja wirklich mit Leuten zu tun, die keine Ahnung haben. Weshalb es besonders witzig ist, solche kleinen Snippets wie dieses hier zu hören.
Also erst mal muss sich jeder selber prüfen, bevor man sich für Dinge bewirbt. Also das glauben nur Politiker, dass sie alles können. Auf die Idee würden wir doch gar nicht kommen.
Glaubst du, dass sie das wirklich glauben?
Nee, auf die Idee würdet ihr nicht kommen. Ihr seid so bescheiden und demütig gegenüber jedem Sachverstand und gegenüber jedem Gegenstand.
Gabor Steingart würde doch in jede Karamjowska-Sendung gehen, egal zu welchem Thema. Der würde doch niemals sagen, sorry, dazu habe ich keine Ahnung. Der würde doch Krebsforschung mit drei Professoren dort diskutieren.
Na gut, ist ja klar, was der sagt. Das Problem ist natürlich die allgemeine Krankenversicherung.
Absolut. Also das große Wetter hier geht weiter. Der Beamtenstaat, das geht ja gar nicht. Wer braucht schon einen Staat? Naja, so einen kleinen Teilbereich hat er jetzt doch noch markiert.
Ein Staat, der uns hilft, beim Gründen hilft, der bei der Öffnung einer Kindertagesstätte hilft, der dabei hilft, dass Menschen sich entfalten können. Das tut unser Staat auf gar keinen Fall. Im besten Falle, und da sind viele wohlmeidende Menschen, aber unser System ist anders gegründet und versteht sich auch anders. Und ja, ich glaube, die Entfesselung ist nicht ein paar Gesetze abschaffen, Bürokratie, ist den Beamtenstaat abschaffen. Also ich gehe schon radikaler an, auf Kernbereiche wie den Ausweis drucken und auch an der Grenze und so weiter. Ich will an der Grenze keine private Armee stehen sehen.
Also so ein bisschen militär, ein bisschen nachtwächter Staat.
Genau, und ein Bundesdrucker.
Ein Nachtwächterstaat, der passt auf, dass das Eigentum morgen noch da ist.
Im Grunde ist das der Nachtwächterstaat.
Und das war's.
Aber wir haben doch klar zu viele Beamten.
Wenn diese Menschen in die Produktion gingen, in produktive Tätigkeiten, das sind ja alles auch Krustentierchen, die verzehren.
Die Beamten, die in den Laden am Laufen halten, sind alles Krustentierchen. Also die Rente, 350 Milliarden im Jahr zahlen wir an die alten Leute. Die Verwaltungsgebühr dafür liegt bei 0,8 Prozent oder so. Da sitzen ganz wenige Leute, die das einfach alles im Griff haben. Wir haben diese Woche ein Urteil gehabt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, glaube ich, zum Thema Riester-Rente. Ja. Es gab einmal den Versuch, zu sagen, wir machen es ein bisschen privatwirtschaftlich. 20 Jahre später entscheidet das Bundesverfassungsgericht, ja, ja, das ist schon nicht korrekt, dass der Versicherungsgeber einfach im Nachhinein seinen Auszahlungsbetrag anpassen kann. Und der konkrete Rentenfaktor, der da strittig war, war, die Allianz-Versicherung hat jemandem 38 Euro als Einheitspreis zugesichert und am Ende gesagt, wir zahlen doch nur 30 aus. Wir kürzen das hier einfach mal von 38 auf 30 runter. So, damit mussten sich, also zum einen vorher in der Planung bei der Allianz, sehr viele Juristen, auch gegen innere moralische Widerstände, sagen, okay, ich bin von meiner eigenen Arbeit nicht betroffen, müssen das planen. Danach müssen sich 20 Jahre Gerichte damit befassen, damit man mal sagt, liebe Leute, Rieser-Rente heißt, es lohnt sich nur, wenn du über 100 Jahre alt wirst.
Ja.
Es hat gar, also hier ist nichts mit, wir werden alle Millionäre und so.
Nein, nein, wir hätten es besser unter das Kopfkissen gelegt.
Also Carlson Maschmeyer wurde Milliardär, das ist der Einzige, der davon profitiert hat. Alle anderen. Rechtsweg ist er offen, wie in der Rechtsstaat so. So, hier wurde also schon gegen die Rente gewettert, wo man sagt, nee, das ist schon ganz gut, wenn wir 350 Milliarden einfach von so ein paar tausend Leuten verwalten lassen, weil die kriegen das einfach hin, das sind Staatsbeamte, die machen das einfach, statt dass wir kleinere Beträge zu viel größeren Nebenkosten, Rechtswege hier, Planung da, ein bisschen Lobbyismus und so weiter, ja. Also das ganze Ding geht überhaupt gar nicht auf, und jetzt will er diese wenigen Beamten, die die Sache noch gerade so über die Bühne bringen hier in Deutschland, ja plötzlich in diese Produktion stecken.
In produktive Tätigkeiten, das sind ja alles auch Krustentierchen, die verzehren ja auf ihren gut bezahlten Beamtenjobs das, was andere, der Stahlarbeiter, der Autoarbeiter, im besten Fall auch ein profitables Medienunternehmen erwirtschaftet hat.
Es ist mir jetzt noch kurz eingefallen, was ist eigentlich mit uns? Wir sind ja gar keine Stahlarbeiter. Ah ja, profitables Medienunternehmen.
Wir hören heute, ich habe diesen Text aus der Süddeutsch mitgebracht, über das Potemkinsche Medienimperium von Wolfram Weimar. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Also es ist wirklich Gänsehaut.
Wir sprechen nämlich auch über den Kulturpass noch mal.
Oh ja, sehr gut, die besten Ideen von Wolfram Weimar, die er sein Leben lang ausgepultet hat heute. Er möchte gerne zeigen, dass die Kritik von Stefan Schulz zum Thema Gabor Steingart hat noch nie ein YouTube-Video selber hochgeladen. Nicht ganz stimmt. Er kennt sich in der Sprache der Computer-Freaks aus.
Diese Systeme sind heute outdated. Und so wie wir beim Computer mit outdated, dann kommt eine neue Diskette rein oder wir gehen in die Cloud. Und wir sind nicht in der Cloud, sondern wir antieren hier noch mit Floppy Disk, um in der Sprache der Computer-Freaks zu sein.
Oh, da kennt sich aber einer richtig aus.
Die Sprache der Computer-Freaks, Floppy Disk.
Nee, wann war das? 1994 oder so?
Ja, im Grunde 1803. Friedrich Merz. Gabor Steingart urteilt jetzt über Friedrich Merz. Wir haben ja gerade gehört, die Politiker kommen bei ihm nicht so gut weg. Robert Habeck zum Beispiel. Hitler, ziemlich gut Führer. Jetzt Friedrich Merz.
Friedrich Merz wäre wahrscheinlich jemand, wenn er jetzt nicht in der Verantwortung wäre, der als Erster zusammen mit Wirtschaftsbossen dort stehen würde und sagen würde, wir brauchen einen Angehender wie Gerhard Schröder. Warum kriegt er das jetzt als Kanzler, zumindest bislang, nicht hin?
Tja, also positiv muss man sagen, er ist wirklich ein Wissender. Alles, was ich hier aufschreibe, weiß er. Ich habe viele gesehen.
Friedrich Merz ist vieles, aber er ist kein Wissender. Der hat keine Ahnung von nichts.
Gut, er hat genau dasselbe Buch wie Gabor Steingart geschrieben damals.
Das stimmt, aber jetzt ohne Quatsch. Es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Friedrich Merz noch niemals ICE gefahren ist.
Ja, könnte sein.
Ich glaube, diese Fahrt in die Ukraine war für ihn das einzige Zugfahren ever. Und er hat einfach zwei Waggons für sich gehabt, den er sich mit Kirsten Dahmer und Macron teilen musste. Das ist für ihn Zugfahren. Er glaubt, das ist Zugfahren. Mediengeschehen ist für ihn, ja, ich bin heute Abend in der AD eingeladen. Und dann wundert er sich, warum das Land nicht auf ihn hört. Er hat doch heute Abend eine Ansage gemacht. Ja. So. Ja. Das ist der Wissende, ja. Und es kann, also dieses Urteil kann man nur sagen, wenn man selber sich zu diesen Wissenden zählt. Ja. Also dass er hier das argumentiert mit Friedrich Merz weiß, was ich weiß, er ist ein Wissender, ist wirklich sehr vielsagend.
Friedrich Merz wäre wahrscheinlich jemand, wenn er da wäre. Warum kriegt er das jetzt als Kanzler, zumindest bislang, nicht hin?
Tja.
Also positiv muss man sagen, er ist wirklich ein Wissender. Alles, was ich hier aufschreibe, weiß er. Ich habe viele Gespräche, nicht jetzt als Kanzler, früher, mit ihm geführt, immer wieder. Er ist ein Wissender. Er kennt auch den Kapitalmarkt. Er kennt die Schwäche des Sozialstaates.
Er kennt den Kapitalmarkt und die Schwächen des Sozialstaates. Ja, das weiß er. Ja, klar. Oh Gott, Onzeimer steigt ein bisschen mit ein.
Jetzt sagen einige, das ist interessant, weil du hast gerade gesagt, Angela Merkel hat immer die großen Krisen benutzt, um zu begründen, warum sie innenpolitische Reformen er nicht anpackt. Jetzt sehen wir Friedrich Merz, der nach Brüssel jettet. Da geht es um das russische Vermögen. Der versucht, Zelensky immer wieder zu treffen. Der versucht, mit Trump eine Brücke zu bauen, sich aber auch klar abzugrenzen, wenn Trump zu weit geht. Also der sich klar, und das war ja auch davor, als jemand der Chef der Atlantikbrücke war, also der sich klar außenpolitisch verortet.
So, Merz klar außenpolitisch verordnet, der Trump auch mal die Schranken weist. Die beiden konnten natürlich noch nicht wissen, wir haben das natürlich auch vorher schon gewusst, also wir brauchten jetzt diese Empirie dafür nicht, aber wenn in dieser Sicherheitsstrategie die Amerikas drinsteht, fuck the you, dann sagt Merz, ja genau, weg damit. Die beiden haben natürlich, vor allem Ronz haben sie später im Podcast gehört, also in seinem Podcast nach diesem Ereignis, ja das war wirklich unklug und so.
Aber wo hat denn sonst auch Merz Trump Paroli geboten? Habe ich irgendwas nicht mitbekommen in den letzten Monaten?
Na ja, eine sehr gute Performance, als Trump ihn 45 Minuten im Oval Office hatte, aber abgelenkt war von seinem Break-Up mit Musk und in den zwei Minuten 37, die er da gesprochen hat, kam der eine Talking Point zur Ukraine und das war schon ganz gut.
Ah ja, okay, das hätte ich beinahe vergessen. Mutig.
Also wir hier, das Milieu, die aufgeklärten, die Wissenden in Deutschland, die brauchen keinen weiteren Vorpaar von Merz vor laufender Kamera, um einfach zu sagen, nee, der ist nur im Ausland, um Innenpolitik zu vermeiden.
Ja.
Und im Ausland gelingt das auch nicht allzu gut, was er da macht.
Und wenn er dann zurückkommt, dann sagt er, da gab es wieder kein deutsches Brot.
Und hier diese anderen Wissenden, die sind dann immer so überrascht. Also ich fand es auch nicht schlecht, Robin Alexander, bis zu dem Ende des Monats im Podcast zu hören, wie er sich dazu äußert, was Merz da gesagt hat. Nur ich denke mir so, äh, warum bist du überrascht? Also warum wartest du immer auf das, klar ist jetzt sein Thema, große emotionale Ereignisse, was dann irgendwie so Ohrpots blitzt. Aber das ist doch völlig klar, dass der Merz so tickt. Also das Fuck the EU, der einfach Programm ist. Wenn die Amerikaner einen Partner brauchen, und auf die EU nicht setzen wollen, dann versucht es doch mit uns. Und die ganze Handelspolitik macht man dann über Katharina Reiche oder was? Also das sind alles keine guten Aussichten.
Wir kriegen bei ihm nicht das, was wir bestellt haben. Und die CDU kriegt nicht, was sie bestellt hat. Ich glaube, sein Hauptproblem ist, dass er kein Politiker ist, tatsächlich.
Ach so.
Ja, was? Also das ist jetzt das Zwischenfazit irgendwie. Von Gabor Steingart über Merz. Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem ist, er ist eigentlich ein guter Mensch und mit Politik sind ja nur schlechte Menschen. Und er ist auch eigentlich kein Politiker. Deutschland muss jetzt jedenfalls restrukturiert werden.
Mir fallen sehr viele Sozialdemokraten ein, mit denen ich absolut konform bin, dass diese Dinge, die ich beschreibe, das ist nicht crazy. Und das ist auch nicht Neoliberalismus. Das ist nicht links nicht.
Nee, das ist weder crazy noch Neoliberalismus.
Neoliberalismus. Das ist nicht links, nicht rechts, was ich vorschlage. Das ist vernünftig. Die Dinge gemeinsam, wie in einer Firma auch. Sozialpartnerschaft heißt ja, man macht das zusammen. Und Deutschland muss restrukturiert werden.
Ja, Sozialpartnerschaft heißt, man macht das zusammen. Nee, Sozialpartnerschaft heißt, dass man die Arbeiter durch Umarmung erdrosselt und nicht sozialpartnerschaftlich vorgeht, wie ja die Reallohnentwicklung und die Entwicklung beim DAX deutlich zeigen. Da gibt es ja einen Unterschied. Und was er hier als vernünftig preist, ist ja einfach nur zu sagen, alles, was dem Interesse der Konzerne dient, ist vernünftig fertig.
Ja, also Sozialpartnerschaft heißt übersetzt ganz konkret, hier hält sich die Politik raus. Und dann bleibt nur noch eine Logik und das ist, der Reichere hat Recht.
Ja.
So, Punkt.
Und so möchte er Deutschland strukturieren. Ich finde auch gut, dass man in diesem Trump-Zeitalter, wo sich wirklich alle vernünftigen Autoren darüber lustig machen, wie sehr Trump Amerika einfach als ein Teil seiner Firma versteht, die Idee hat, wir sollten das wie eine Firma machen. Na ja, Benchmarks, ganz wichtig. Die Gefahren sehen und vor allem Tendenzen und Trends ablesen.
Deswegen muss ich die AfD nicht heiraten und auch keine Koalition machen. Den ganzen braunen Kram draußen lassen.
So, den ganzen braunen Kram draußen lassen. Und deswegen, also man hört schon im Gespräch so, man sollte schon mal mit der AfD so ein bisschen, man muss ja jetzt nicht die heiraten. Aber so eine kleine Anbahnung, so ein Dating, ein bisschen Formeln, das kann man mal machen.
Ist ja da, dieser braune Kram, Gabor. Wenn du sagst, du willst mit denen eine Mehrheit, dann brauchst du da ja auch diejenigen, die mit Identitären zusammen Dinge machen, die rechtsradikal sind. Also da gibt es ja nur eine Menge von.
Aber es gibt vielleicht auch die anderen. Ich würde das Gespräch suchen. Und es wird ein Regierungschef kommen, glaub mir Paul, der das Gespräch sucht mit denen, die das Land reformieren wollen und keine...
Mit einer Partei, die vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz so bewertet wird.
Tja.
Tja. Der Kommentar lautet, tja.
Vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz so bewertet wird.
Tja. Ja, aber sie ist zulässig, sie ist erlaubt. Sie sitzt da im Parlament vor ihm.
Sie ist zulässig, sie ist erlaubt, sie sitzt im Parlament, ja, weil die Demos zum Thema, könnte sie bitte mal überprüfen und im Zuge dessen gleich mal alle Parteien noch zu klein sind. Aber wahrscheinlich gehe ich mit auf die Straße. Soll ja Demos geben.
Das ist der Oppositionspartei. Das meine ich, ein Politiker muss sich die Mehrheit holen. Pass auf, oder er sagt, ich mache mit denen, das ist die andere Alternative und wir ziehen in Neuwahlen. Und ich überzeug die Deutschen, jetzt packen wir es gemeinsam an. Und wir kommen aus der Nichtwahlgeschichte raus. 25 Prozent, also ein Viertel der Erwachsenen Menschen, sind in dieser Fraktion, wählen nicht. Das ist jetzt ein Problem. Und ich versuche, den mittigen Teil der AfD zu gewinnen. Ich versuche die FDP-Wähler jemals.
Gibt es denn da einen mittigen Teil? Siehst du da bei der AfD einen mittigen Teil?
Ich kenne mich zu wenig aus. Ich kenne...
Ach so. Jetzt gerade kennt man sich leider kurz zu wenig aus. Ja, das mit dem Führer ist eine supergeile Sache gewesen.
Aber wir können schon mal lösen. Alles, was Gabor Steingart vorschlägt, würde Alice Weidel so 100 Prozent mittragen. Also ich wüsste überhaupt gar nicht, wo Gabor Steingart und Alice Weidel irgendeinen Disput haben. Ich hätte bis vor diesem Podcast noch gesagt, naja, Gabor Steingart würde vermutlich sich mit der deutschen Geschichte wesentlich kritischer auseinandersetzen wollen als Alice Weidel. Aber nachdem wir gehört haben, wir haben da eh so einen kleinen Defekt, weil wir Angst vor einem Führer haben, würde ich sagen, gibt es auch diesen Anknüpfungspunkt nun.
Also Rente abschaffen und das ganze Geld zu Goldman Six bringen, ist Alice Weidels Programm. Ja, das muss sie eigentlich im Konflikt mit Höcke gerade durchboxen.
Genau.
So jetzt kommt Gabor Steingart einfach und sagt, nö, die hat schon recht.
Gibt es denn da einen mittigen Teil? Siehst du da bei der AfD einen mittigen Teil?
Ich kenne mich zu wenig aus. Ich kenne sehr wenige.
Dafür sagst du das aber sehr leichtfertig, dass man einfach mal mit denen doch mal ein paar Mehrheiten sich holen sollte.
Naja, was heißt leichtfertig? Wir stehen vor der Frage, ob das Land sich selber reformieren kann oder ob die AfD weiter durchmarschiert. Also wenn man die Gefahr der AfD ernst...
Also gegen die AfD hilft, die Reform zu machen, die die AfD will.
Am besten mit der AfD zusammen.
Ja, dann haben wir sie besiegt.
Dann kann man ja nicht mit dem Rezept der letzten fünf Jahre, das zu Verdopplung, Verdreifahrung, ich weiß nicht, kein Aggregat in Deutschland ist schneller gewachsen, außer der Sozialstaat vielleicht als die AfD. Die AfD wächst schneller als die Börse. Also die AfD ist sehr schnell zu wachsen. Irgendwas kann ja nicht richtig sein.
Ja. Hier, das war ja sehr offenbar gerade, ne? Also so eine echte Ehrlichkeit von Gabor Steingart. Alles nur so in Wachstumskurven denken. Und Wachstum kann auch schlecht sein, wenn die falschen Sachen wachsen. Und nachdem er eigentlich gerade zwei Minuten lang im Fokus-Korridor AfD war, bringt er da noch mal den Sozialstaat begrifflich mit rein, weil der wächst noch schneller als die AfD und ist auch schlecht. Also das ist doch wirklich... Wahnsinn. Wieso, also wieso kämpfen wir überhaupt in irgendwelchen Sachen gegen eine AfD? Und Gabor Steingart macht aber jeden Morgen einfach so ein Briefing.
Ja. Ja, ja, ich mein...
Das sind doch hier wirklich, und ich weiß, das klingt jetzt beleidigend und gerne Anwaltsbriefe, aber das, was ich hier gehört habe gerade, ist wirklich Verfassungsfeindlichkeit. Das, je nachdem, wie eine Podcast-Kontrollnote aussehen würde, die man dann formuliert, aber das Verfassungsgericht würde, glaube ich, sagen Vorsicht hier. Das ist nicht ganz konform, so mit typischer Erzählung, die man erwartet.
Meine These ist sowieso, dass wir mit dieser permanenten Konzentration auf die Faschisten ganz übersehen haben, was sich in der Mitte tut und dass das alles gar nicht verhandelt wird. Wir reden die ganze Zeit über Propaganda und das kommt ja dann immer von Russland oder von der AfD. Nö, das kommt hier ganz aus der Mitte und wird von breiten Teilen der Medienöffentlichkeit getragen, wie man ja sieht, weil er hier prominent im Rondsheimer Podcast ist, zum Springer-Konzern in gewisser Weise dazugehört. Und nur von dieser Seite aus ist überhaupt der Rechtsdruck zu vollziehen. Also es wird ja nicht in Volksaufstand geben und dann übernimmt Höcke plötzlich alle Landesregierungen und dann wird alles gleichgeschaltet. Das ist ja nicht vorstellbar, sondern es geht nur so, dass der Rechtsdruck sich über diese Mitte vollzieht, die alle Türen so langsam öffnet oder zumindest schon mal die Fenster auf Kipp stellt. Und das ist etwas, was aus der Mitte kommen wird. Und da wird man sich dann eher mit Alice Weidel verbünden als mit einem Krupaller oder Höcke. Das mag dann sein, aber das macht es ja nicht besser.
Genau. Also bei Ferdinand von Schirach, das ist heute gar nicht so groß Thema hier, aber dieses Wetter gegen Migration. Und das muss man doch jetzt mal einsehen. Und die ganzen Gerichte sind über, die ganzen Ausländer und so, das geht ja gar nicht. Das war da schon ein Thema komplett auf AfD-Linie. Und hier alles andere. Die ganze Sozialstaatsdiskurs auf dieser AfD-Linie. Man muss sagen, er hält ein bisschen gut nach, so hält gut dagegen.
Wenn man von der Sache herkommt, muss man über die Sache sprechen, nicht über Koalition, nicht über die ganzen anti-humanen Ideen der AfD.
Aber ich finde, man muss, sorry, dass ich dazwischen gehe, aber zuallererst darüber sprechen, was die AfD angeht. Weil ich kann noch nicht sagen, ich öffne mich jetzt für eine Partei, die vom Verfassungsschutz als gesichert rechtsextrem bewertet wird und ignoriere das irgendwie und sage, naja, ist jetzt halt so.
Aber was ist dann deine Antwort?
Ja, das ist aber genau die Haltung. Wer BEP-Wachstum verspricht, kann so schlimm nicht sein. Und wir geben, wir kennen ja zum Beispiel auch von Hayek diese Aussagen, wie ist das, wenn eine Diktatur da ist? Dann würde der auch sagen, ja, bevor sozialistische Ideen sich breit machen, hat er ja auch so formuliert, ist dann eine faschistische Diktatur vorzuziehen. Nicht auf Dauer gestellt, aber das kann zunächst einmal doch weiterhelfen, dass man wieder ein bisschen auf Trab kommt.
Ja, das Problem ist halt, in dem AfD-Programm, das ja Steingart nicht liest, weil er einfach nur von Weidel fasziniert ist, steht drin, Rentenniveau 70 Prozent. Also es ist ganz unvereinbar wiederum mit dem, was er da labert. Also man wüsste gar nicht, also wenn jetzt eröffnet der AfD Tür und Tor und dann ein Jahr später, wie jetzt Rente 70 Prozent, was? Also ich wollte eigentlich 47, nicht 70. Steingart meint es wirklich, der ist ganz überzeugt.
Mit den Konzernschefs, mit denen du redest, du bist wahrscheinlich einer der best vernetzten in der deutschen Wirtschaft, sagen das viele das gleiche, was du mir jetzt gerade gesagt hast.
Ja, und zwar die sagen alle dasselbe. Da ist ganz viel braune Soße. Damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Damit darf ein demokratischer Politiker nicht koalieren. Nicht koalieren und dann und dann kommt der Punkt 4. Aber wir müssen ein Gespräch trotzdem beginnen darüber, wie Deutschland reformiert werden kann.
Ja, das heißt ja einfach als Arbeitsaufgabe für die AfD. Bitte haltet die Identitären klein oder vielleicht könnten wir da ein Verbot hinbekommen. Lasst den Höcke draußen. Der kann höchstens dann noch auf Landesebene den Zampano machen. Aber bitte auf Bundesebene übernimmt das neoliberale Programm von Steingart vollends. Und bei Fragen der Migration haben wir sowieso keine Differenzen mehr. Insofern ist das ja eine ausgemachte Sache. Das Einzige, was man eben nicht möchte, ist, dass man jetzt zu sehr jetzt vielleicht noch die Waffen-SS oder so glorifiziert. Das wäre wirklich ein bisschen unangenehm. Auch gerade im Ausland sieht das bisschen hässlich aus. Aber sonst können wir eigentlich alles machen.
Milanovic beschreibt es ganz wunderbar. Jelzin, besoffen, aus dem Amt, wie auch immer. Und ganz Russland droht einfach diesen Oligarchen zum Opfer zu fallen. Also kommt so ein Typ auf die Idee und sagt, komm wir nehmen aber diesen Putin. So ein kleiner, zarter Typ, der ist so schmächtig, der äußert sich nie. Keine Gefahr.
Der hat keine Ideologie.
Genau. Und dann glaubt man, man könnte mit ihm gemeinsame Sachen machen gegen die Oligarchen. Ein Jahr später ist Vladimir Putin der Zar der Oligarchen. Und 25 Jahre später ist er es immer noch. Also diese ganze Idee, die er hier hat mit, ja, ich möchte den Sozialstaat abräumen und die SPD macht ja irgendwie nicht mit, die linken und grünen sind eh verloren und vergessen, lass uns doch mit der AfD machen. Aber diese ganze braune Soße, das ist ja nicht so wichtig. Wir wollen ja nur kurz den Sozialstaat abräumen. Danach geben die uns das Land bestimmt zurück.
Dann machen wir das.
So, und dann ist irgendwann 2055 und wir müssen wieder Bücher schreiben über, dass man mit dem Führer war, auch beim zweiten Mal keine gute Idee. Ja, das droht hier einfach. Kostenverkleinerung, ja. Wir müssen jetzt die Kruste verkleinern, letzter Clip.
Und wenn wir uns auf dieses Ziel, wir vergrößern jetzt den produktiven Kern, verständigen, dann leiten sich viele Maßnahmen genau daraus ab. Weil dann sortiere ich die Welt, vergrößert es die Kruste oder den Kern. Rentenreform im Bundestag? Eine eklatante Kostenvergrößerung. Weg damit. Tariftreuegesetz, wo jetzt jede kleine Firma Tariflöhne zahlen muss, also Lohnerhöhung. Schadet ihnen auf den Weltmärkten. Weg damit. Also verstehst du, ich brauche ein sehr klares Raster. Das versucht dieses Buch jedem Menschen zu geben. Dieses klare Navigationssystem.
Ja, dieses Buch sagt den Menschen, du sollst verarmen, damit es der Klasse, die ich repräsentiere, besser geht.
Du bist Größte, du musst weg.
Ja. Und wenn du im Kern bist, dann hast du dich gefälligst noch viel mehr anzustrengen, weil ich gerne für meine Klasse mehr rausholen will.
Ja, das ist wirklich eklig einfach, das ist ganz, man will es einfach abschütteln.
Ja, deswegen, ich will das hier mal als Ansatz machen, ich will also nichts mehr hören auf irgendwelchen Podiumsdiskussionen. Man wird ja doch viel eingeladen. Ja, was tun wir gegen die Gefahr von rechts? Und damit wird immer die AfD gemeint und Fake News im Internet. Dann stellt bitte die Frage, was tun wir gegen den Springer Verlag? Da können wir gerne mal darüber diskutieren. Was tun wir gegen öffentlich-rechtliche Talkshows, die mit solchen Leuten besetzt sind? Ich will nur noch über diese Fragen diskutieren. Ich habe keine Lust, mich daran aufzuhalten, ob man die Publizistik in Schnellroda verbieten sollte oder nicht. Die spielt keine Rolle. Hier wird die große Politik gemacht. Diese Leute drehen am Großen Rat.
So ist es. Termine. Ich war bei Lanz. Mit mir war dort die Chef-Volkswirtin oder was auch immer der Welt.
Bei der Welt bekommt jeder so einen Chef-Titel.
Ja, das sind alle immer Chefs. Also sie ist irgendwie die Wirtschaftschefin, keine Ahnung. Frau Siems und zwei Professoren und Institutsverantwortliche. Einmal aus dem IFO-Institut, einmal vom Bevölkerungsforschungsinstitut hier, von BIP. Und freut euch bitte auf zwei Argumentationen. Zum einen, alle feiern immer so Hartz-IV-Reformen ab und so. Und ich will das auch an niemandem madig reden. Nur ich denke mir, vor 20 Jahren waren die Armen dran. Jetzt brauchen wir wieder eine Sozialstaatsreform. Jetzt soll es um die Reichen gehen. Zweites Argument. Und da bin ich auch erst drauf gestoßen, als ich mich auf die Sendung vorbereitete, weil der Herr Peichel vom IFO-Institut selber da war als Autor. Typischerweise sitzt man ja im Fernsehen immer mit irgendwelchen anderen Politikern oder so oder Leute, die mal so ein Kommentar schreiben. Aber Leute, die so echte Forschung machen, das ist schon was Besonderes. Und der Herr Peichel hat letztes Jahr einen Text mitverantwortet, der davon handelt, wie sich die Lohnentwicklung von 1983 bis heute entwickelt hat. Das ist also genau die Erwerbsbiografiephase der Boomer, die heute in Rente gehen, die Deutschland zur drittgrößten Volkswirtschaft der Welt gemacht haben. Die haben also richtig reingebuttert. Sie haben während ihrer Lebensarbeitszeit das BIP verdoppelt. Wirtschaftswachstum 100 Prozent. Und es war natürlich die Frage, die ich an den Text stellte, wie haben sich denn die Löhne in der Zeit entwickelt? Auch verdoppelt? Und der Herr Peichel schreibt von Dekaden der Stagnation und Reallohnverlust. Und da liegt natürlich die Frage auf der Hand, wieso ist denn dieses produktive Wachstum niemals in die Rentenkasse angekommen? Warum reden wir hier über zu wenig Junge, zu viele Ältere und so weiter und so fort? Hat es vielleicht, wie Moes Höfken schon schreibt, gar nichts mit Jung und Alt, sondern mit Reich und Arm zu tun? Und nachdem dann die Frau Siems ewig lange ausführt und hier und da und so, habe ich dann die Rückfrage an sie, wo denn das Leben in ihren Ausführungen vorkommt. Denn ich habe ja auch daran teilgenommen und ich habe das eigentlich, glaube ich, es war keine Vater Morgane, als es hieß, da ist irgendwie eine Lehman-Bank-Pleite gegangen und jetzt ist da irgendwie ein Angriffskrieg und jetzt sind da irgendwie Inflationen 10 Prozent. Ach ja, eine Corona-Krise haben wir auch noch. Findet einfach gar nicht statt. Sie guckt einfach so in die Bücher und sagt, also für mich ist das alles, ist alles gleich anything to me. Wie so ein Host da aus Westworld und so. Na ja, also es ist die letzte Sendung von Lands des Jahres. Ich glaube, die kommt am Donnerstag.
Prima. Und noch einen Termin im Januar hattest du?
Am 9. Januar in Erlangen abends mit Obie Florian Janik. Gespräche über die Kinderwüste. Für ganz Ausgewählte ein, jetzt fällt mir der richtige Name nicht ein, aber es ist superwitzig. Denn ich habe ja gesagt, das ist ja direkt neben Nürnberg. Ich würde gerne mal die historischen Städten, als das mit dem Führer noch funktioniert hat und so sehen. Und bei mir hat sich Thorsten gemeldet. Und es ist superwitzig, wenn man fragt, also er ist Rundgangsleiter, möchte ich damit sagen. Die Pointe ist, er nennt sich Rundgangsleiter, weil natürlich, also Guide könnte man auch noch sagen, aber alles, was Führer im Namen hat, geht natürlich nicht. Also haben wir den Rundgangsleiter Thorsten gefunden. Thomas aus dem Fernsehpodcast und ich werden also einen Rundgang mit Thorsten machen. Und wir hätten vielleicht noch so ein oder zwei, aber bitte nicht einfach nur flapsige E-Mails schreiben jetzt, sondern wirklich so richtig kleine Bewerbungen, warum ihr mit uns da fünf, sechs Stunden mit verbringen wollt.
An Stefan, an deinen Adresse.
An mail.stephanschulz.com, dann nehme ich das gerne in Begutachtung. Und dann können wir uns da einen schönen Tag machen.
Wir werden also jetzt in den Salon rübergehen und sprechen dann über Branko Milanovic, The Great Global Transformation über den Nationalmarkt-Liberalismus in einer multipolaren Welt. So der Untertitel. Es ist ein sensationelles Buch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir da gleich darüber diskutieren werden. Ich hatte eigentlich angekündigt, dass ich das Buch von Thomas Wagner bespreche. Ich habe mich nicht gegen das Buch entschieden. Das kommt nämlich dann im nächsten Salon. Aber wir müssen uns auf einen Text viel intensiver konzentrieren. Ich habe da so viel zu sagen, dass es einfach schade wäre, wenn ich das Sachbuch dann nur kurz verhandle. Denn ich habe 150 Seiten der EKD gelesen, der Evangelischen Kirche Deutschlands. Die haben sich zu Krieg und Frieden geäußert. Und es ist empörend. Es ist skandalös, dieses Dokument. Ich bin ja schon aus der Kirche ausgetreten. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wenn Leute das jetzt hier hören werden und die in der Kirche sind, wie sie sich dazu verhalten. Ich will nur kurz sagen, man kann ganz leicht aus der Kirche austreten. Es ist ganz einfach. Man braucht nur schnell zur Stadtverwaltung, braucht wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen Termin. Und das ist ein Gespräch von fünf Minuten. Also man muss sich auch nicht rechtfertigen, sondern einfach nur was unterschreiben. Es ist nicht zu fassen, wie der christliche Pazifismus hier nicht nur abgeräumt wird, sondern wie hier eine Kirche für Musterung, für Wehrpflicht plädiert, für atomare Aufrüstung und sogar noch das Fliehen vor Krieg unter Bedingungen stellt. Also ich bin so empört darüber und glaube ich muss da ganz lange drüber reden, habe hier fünf Seiten Exzerpt. Das wird also das große Thema, das zweite für mich im Salon sein. Außerdem noch einen Roman aus Japan über einen Tokyo Sympathy Tower, so heißt der Titel, in dem die Kriminellen leben sollen und die sollen dann aber paradiesisch leben, denn die Sprachpolitik will es, dass über alles nur noch positiv gesprochen wird. Es ist aber jetzt nicht einfach so ein antipolitical correctness Roman, sondern ein bisschen differenzierter, interessanter. Fünf Prozent des Romans wurden mit Chechie Petit geschrieben, hat die Autorin auch gesagt. Außerdem beschäftigen wir uns nochmal mit dem Kulturpass und ziehen da Bilanz. Und es wird von mir auch noch einen Musiktipp geben, nämlich es gibt eine neue Winterreise-Einspielung. Ich habe ja schon mal die Winterreise hier von André Schuhn empfohlen. Nun, Johannes Martin Krenzler, grandios.
Okay.
Aladin El-Mafaalani hat ein Buch geschrieben. Wichtiges Thema Vertrauen und Misstrauen in unserer durchrüttelten Welt. Dieses Buch ist so schlecht, ich konnte es gar nicht glauben. Für mich rangiert leider der Autor jetzt Haaresbreite über Markus Gabriel. Oh je. Es ist wirklich vernichtend. Und die Potemkinische Mediengruppe, die süddeutsche Zeitung Jörg Henschel, hat sich Wolfram Weimers gigantisches Medienimperium angeschaut. 293 Abonnenten. The Verge hat einen Text aufgegriffen, den es schon woanders gab, nämlich bei Benjamin Riley. Die haben ihn gebeten, nochmal ein Argument auszubauen, der selbst ist Mitglied einer, wie nennt man das, NGO, irgendwie Cognitive Resonance, die also gegen den AI-Hype ankämpft. Das kommt dir sehr entgegen und ich finde es auch wahnsinnig interessant, aber es stellen sich noch soziologische Fragen, die wir gleich mal aufgreifen. Und Sven Kalisch hat Born, Rich or Die, Trying, eine wunderbare Auftröselung über die deutsche Erbengesellschaft mit der Ankündigung, weitere thematische Texte anschließen zu lassen. Ich sehe hier die Anbahnung einer Enzyklopädie zum Thema, was uns alle interessiert. Und zwar bei Substack einfach so als Privatvergnügen. Und das ist ja auch ein Format, das ich immer besser finde so, dass jetzt immer mehr Leute immer mehr Kram machen. Und von daher hier Blogosphere 2.0 oder so.
Wunderbar. Das ist auch zugleich, wenn man in den Salon geht, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Es ist ganz einfach, man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort wird man dann zu Steady geführt. Es ist alles selbsterklärend. Man kann dann einfach ein Abo machen. Am besten ein Jahresabo gleich. Das ist dann auch günstiger. Es ist aber auch für diejenigen, die schon bei Patreon sind, möglich, dort den Salon zu abonnieren. Oder wer bei Apple es ganz bequem haben will, kann das auch darüber tun. Bei Steady gibt es jetzt auch noch die Möglichkeit, weil ja bald Weihnachten ist, dass man den Salon verschenkt. Man kann also für ein Jahr irgendjemanden den Salon verschenken. Und dieses Abo wird dann auch nach einem Jahr aufgelöst, wenn die Person es dann nicht für sich selbst verlängern will. Das geht natürlich dann auch. Aber man ist dann nicht ein Leben lang daran gebunden an dieses Geschenk, sondern kann für ein Jahr den...
Du musst deine Wirtschaft übernehmen, wie für die Neuanköpplige.
Eben nicht. Es ist also ganz selbsterklärend und einfach. Also wir freuen uns sehr, wenn ihr den Salon unterstützt auf diese Weise und den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt. Es gibt ja dann auch in diesem Winter, in diesem Dezember noch einen Live-Salon, nämlich in der nächsten Woche sind wir noch einmal in der CAS. Wir geben auch gleich noch mal im Salon die vier Termine durch, wann man uns in der CAS erleben kann.
Nächstes Jahr. Genau.
Nächstes Jahr.
Ja, so ist es. Ihr kriegt im Steady-Archiv alle Folgen. Nur jetzt gerade ziehen die Dateien auf einen neuen Server. Das heißt, ab nächster Woche sind die sehr viel schneller runterladbar. Und jetzt gerade kann es ein paar Hick-Ups geben. Aber Steady kümmert sich, haben sie mir versprochen.
Wunderbar. Also dort findet man dann übrigens auch, weil wir jetzt ein paar E-Mails bekommen haben nach Geschenktipps. Nun ja, wir haben jetzt ja so viele Bücher besprochen. In den letzten Monaten auch noch mal Einzelempfehlungen dabei gehabt. Ich habe ja fast jedes Mal was Literarisches noch dabei. Da findet man jetzt wirklich Geschenkideen noch und nöcher. Ich glaube, wir brauchen jetzt nicht noch mal extra zehn Bücher nennen, die man verschenken kann. Da ist alles dabei oder den Salon verschenken.
In der Ansicht habe ich jetzt meinen Freundeskreis erweitert um diese ganzen KI-Sachen. Es ist einfach nur der Zeit geschuldet, dass neuezwanzige.de noch nicht so eine richtig große Stöberseite ist, wo auch alle Argumente, die wir zu den hunderten Büchern, die wir besprochen haben, noch mal schön durchsuchbar und so weiter. Also wenn ihr dann nächstes Jahr Geschenke sucht und kluge Sachen verschenken wollt, dann können wir bei neuezwanziger.de Sachen anbieten. Das haben die Föhtons in Deutschland, die auch zum Jahresende immer so jeder Redakteur schreibt mal kurz drei Zeilen zu irgendwas, noch nicht gesehen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da kommt.
Der Schatz wird gehoben.
Gut, dann bis gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.